so i'm looking forward to the end of
this problem as much as i'm guessing you
are and i think we're in the home
stretch we just have to simplify this to
get the possible values for x so let's
simplify what we have here in the
radical so let's say square root of 3
minus 2. that's going to be square root
of 3 and we're going to square this
whole thing that's going to be square
root of 3 squared which is 3
minus 2 times their product so that's
minus 4 square roots of 3 and then plus
2 squared so plus 4
plus 4 and then we have minus 4
times square root of 3 times square root
of 3 is 3 square root of 3 times 1 is
plus the square root of 3 and then
negative 2 times square root of 3 is
negative 2 square roots of 3 and the
negative 2 times 1 is negative 2. so
this is going to be equal 3 plus 4 is 7
minus 4
square roots of 3
minus so let's see this three and this
negative two over here that becomes a
one so that becomes a one and then the
square root of three minus two square
roots of three that just becomes a minus
a square root of three so that just
becomes minus or negative square root of
three
my brain is starting to hurt so you have
a negative four times one so it's minus
four and then a negative four times
negative squares of three so plus four
square roots of three and thank god
something has finally simplified here
and so this is that
cancels out with that and so you have 7
minus 4 is equal to 3. so the whole
thing under the radical sign is the
square root of 3. so then this becomes
this becomes our potential values for x
x is equal to 2 minus the square root of
3 plus or minus the square root of this
thing which sample simplified to the
square root of 3
times the square root of 3
all of that over
2 square roots of 3
minus 4. so let's try to see what our
answers could be if we if we add a
square root of 3 so one answer is if we
add the square if we go with the plus
option if we go with the plus option
this would be 2 minus square roots of 3
plus square roots of 3. so it would be 2
the square roots of 3 will just cancel
out 2 over
2 root 3
minus 4. divide the numerator and the
denominator by two and we get one over
the square root of three
minus two
and then to rationalize this
we wanna multiply it times the square
root of three plus two over the square
root of 3 plus 2. we do that so that
when we take the product here it takes
the form b squared minus a squared so
this is equal to the square root of 3
plus 2
all of that over
all of that over let's see did i do this
all of that over
3 squared or square root of 3 squared is
now 3
3 minus 4
3 minus 4. so this is going to be equal
to this part here is negative 1. and so
we can view it as negative and i'll just
write it as 2 plus the square root of 3
2 plus
the square root of 3. so that's one
possible value of x
and the other possible value of x
if we subtract the square root of 3 so
then on the numerator we're going to
have 2 minus square root of 3 minus the
square root of 3 that's 2 minus 2 square
roots of 3
over we could write this as negative 4
plus 2 square roots of 3
2 square roots of 3. the first thing we
might want to do is just divide the
numerator and the denominator by 3. i
swapped
these down here to multiply divide the
numerator and denominator by 2 so this
is equal to
1 minus the square root of 3
over
negative two plus the square root of
three
and now we can rationalize this by
multiplying it by negative two minus the
square root of three over negative two
minus the square root of three
and what do we get here
what do we get here so this gives us
so in the denominator we're going to get
so this is going to be equal to in the
denominator we're going to have negative
2 times negative 2 is 4
4 minus 3. so we just get a 1 so this is
equal to 1 in the denominator the
numerator 1 times negative so let me
just multiply 1 times negative 2 minus
square root of 3. so it's negative 2
minus the square root of 3.
and then the negative square root of 3
times negative two is plus two square
roots of three and then negative square
roots of three times negative square
roots of three is plus
three
and so you have three minus two is one
and then two roots three minus a square
root of 3 is plus the square root of 3.
so our two possible x this is kind of
exciting this was an unbelievably hairy
problem
unbelievably hairy and if any of you all
know a faster way to do this problem
let me know i've thought a lot about it
a lot doesn't seem like there is a
faster way to do this problem
but my possible x values are negative 2
plus square root of 3
or
1 plus the square root of 3. now we have
to be careful if it wasn't enough that
we got this far we did so much work we
finally got these answers we have to be
very careful
because both of those are options this
is one of the options and then this is
the other option so and once again these
are those multiple correct choice
answers so you can actually
select more than one answer here or you
need to select maybe need to select more
than one answer so you might after doing
all of that work say oh finally okay bam
and bam but be very careful remember the
context remember the context of the
problem these sides had to be positive
and if you put this number in here all
the sides will not be positive in
particular if if x was 2 plus the square
root of negative of this value right
here this value over here is going to be
i don't know 3 point something something
if you took the negative of that and you
put it right here for c you're going to
get a negative
distance for c and c cannot be negative
it's the length of a side of a triangle
so a is not a valid choice so these guys
are really trying to trip people up the
correct answer
is only is only b
that was
tiring